im niedersächsischen emsland wurde diese
bahnstrecke saniert die 25 kilometer
zwischen laden und werte kosten satte
8,4 millionen euro
aber ein richtiger bahnstrecke ist das
irgendwie noch nicht denn bisher fahren
hier gar keine züge
es herrscht gähnende leere wo eigentlich
der güterverkehr rollen sollte hier ist
nichts wo die bahn hinfahren kann
das ist einfach eine schande im prinzip
normalerweise müsste man sich vorher
überlegen und dann dass man dann auch
das nutzen kann für mich ist es eine
geld verbrennungsmaschine ich denke
nicht dass das genutzt wird
dementsprechend was die kosten angeht
in den letzten drei jahren wurde die
strecke für viel geld saniert neue
schienen verlegt auch wenn diese
übergänge gestaltet das problem die
unternehmen die das gleis wollten nutzen
die teure bahnstrecke jetzt aber gar
nicht und so sieht die frisch renovierte
strecke an vielen stellen so aus als
seien sie schon wieder kurz vor der
stilllegung dass hier schon vor längerer
zeit ein baum auf die schienen gefallen
ist hat offensichtlich niemand bemerkt
wie auch es fährt hier ja keiner
aber warum steckt der landkreis emsland
so viel geld in eine bahnstrecke
die die wirtschaft dann doch nicht
braucht wir fragen im kreishaus nach
hier will sich niemand vor der kamera
äußern
schriftlich heißt es interesse wurde in
vorgesprächen zur sanierung der strecke
von hiesigen unternehmen immer wieder
signalisiert
insofern ist es unserer auffassung nach
lediglich eine frage der zeit dass
dieses infrastrukturangebot genutzt wird
profitieren will von den neuen schienen
eigentlich die stadt erhalte das
gewerbegebiet soll attraktiver werden
der stadtdirektor ist von seiner
bahnstrecke felsenfest überzeugt leider
ist es so dass wir über keine autobahnen
und auch nicht über wasserstraßen
verfügen
und deswegen ist die schiene neben dem
straßenverkehr die einzige möglichkeit
um unser gebiet attraktiver zu gestalten
hier auf der grünen wiese will die stadt
nun auch noch einen neuen güterbahnhof
bauen wer soll den alten ersetzen den
schon keiner brauchte die emsländer
können mit dem schienenprojekt überhaupt
nichts an
langen dass die saniert worden ist sehe
ich überhaupt nicht ein weil das sind
steuergelder verschwendet worden dass
ich vorher einfach wir müssen die opfer
des clubs werden würde
von den firmen wenigstens für
eisenbahnfreunde passiert was alle paar
monate wird hier die hümmlinger
kreisbahn mit ihrem museumszug gut das
ist sehr hübsch anzusehen aber für die
vielen millionen doch ein bisschen wenig